Let's add some more rational
expressions.
So let's say I have 1 over
x squared minus 9.
And to that I'm going to
add 2 over x squared
plus 5x, plus 6.
So just like we did when
we first learned to add
fractions, or to add rational
numbers, we always had to come
up with a common denominator.
So once again, we're going to
have to come up with a common
denominator.
And what we really want to do
is find the least common
multiple of these
two expressions.
And when I say that, let
me just remind you.
Let's say we wanted to
add 1/4 plus 1/6.
Well, we know that 1/4 is 1 over
2 times 2, and that 1/6
is 1 over 2 times 3.
So to be able to add these two
things, we incrementally-- we
both have a common 2.
We both have this common 2.
But in order for this guy to
go into whatever our common
denominator is, we're
going to have to be
divisible by another 2.
So let me do that.
So our common denominator's
going to have to be-- we have
this 2 in each of them.
So that takes care
of that first 2.
But then we need the second 2.
We need the second 2 there.
2 times a second 2.
And then we need this 3 here.
We need this 3 here.
We have to have all of the prime
factors of both of them.
This has two 2's, so this
guy has to have two 2's.
This guy has a 2 and a
3, so this guy has to
have a 2 and a 3.
And so our least common multiple
here is 2 times 2,
times 3, which is 12.
And then we can add
accordingly.
That is our common
denominator.
That's the least common
multiple.
You could have just multiplied
these two out, but you would
have gotten 24, and that's
larger than necessary.
You could have still worked it
out, but you would have had
more simplifying left
for you to do.
The same idea we can
do right here.
The same idea we can do here.
We can factor both of these
denominators, so x squared,
that is x plus 3,
times x minus 3.
It's just a difference
of squares.
And x squared plus 5x, plus 6.
That is what?
That is x plus 2,
times x plus 3.
2 times 3 is 6.
2 plus 3 is 5.
So our common denominator's
going to be what?
What's going to be our
common denominator?
Let me clear up this real
estate over here.
What's our common denominator
going to be?
Our common denominator-- so this
is going to be equal to--
our common denominator's going
to be-- our common
denominator's going to have
to have an x plus 3 in it.
And that takes care of this
x plus 3 as well.
It's going to have an
x minus 3 in it.
It's going to have to have
an x minus 3 in it.
So that's an x minus 3.
And it's going to have
that x plus 2 in it.
Another way you could have
thought about is, like, look,
it's going to have to have all
of the factors of this guy,
which are x plus 3, times
x minus 3. x plus 3
times x minus 3.
And then once you write those
down, you say, well, it also
has to have all of the
factors for this guy.
Well, we already have an x plus
3 there, so we just have
to only add on the x plus 2.
And that saves us from
multiplying both of these
expressions together.
This is the least common
denominator.
Now, if this is the least common
denominator, what do we
have to change the 1 by?
Well, let me actually rewrite
this a little bit.
Well, I'll write it like this.
So what do you have to do to
go from-- if I start with 1
over x squared-- let me write it
this way-- 1 over x plus 3,
times x minus 3.
This and this is the
exact same thing.
If I want an x plus 2 in
the denominator, what
do I have to do?
I have to multiply the numerator
and the denominator
by x plus 2.
So this expression right here,
which is this expression right
here, will become x plus 2 over
x plus 3, times x minus
3, times x plus 2.
Those would cancel out and
you're just left with a 1.
That's that right there.
So this is the first term.
That is this term.
This term over here, the second
term over here, this is
2 over x plus 2,
times x plus 3.
That's in its original form.
Now, if we also want an
x minus 3 here in the
denominator, we can multiply
it by x minus 3
over x minus 3.
Or essentially, we
can multiply the
numerator by x minus 3.
So this is going to be equal
to 2 times x minus 3 is 2x
minus 6 over x plus 2, times
x plus 3, times x minus 3.
So this expression right here
is the exact same thing as
this expression right
over here.
So if we were to add these two
expressions, they have the
same denominator.
I just switched the order
that I'm multiplying.
But they're the exact same
denominator, which is exactly
the same thing as this.
So this, this first expression,
we're going to get
our x plus 2 here.
x plus 2 over all of this would
cancel, and you'd get 1
over x plus 3, times x minus
3, over 1 over x
squared minus 9.
And then to that you're going
to add plus 2x minus 6.
And why am I adding
2x minus 6?
Because the second term is 2x
minus 6 over all of this
business, because we were
just multiplying.
This would also be written as 2
times x minus 3, over all of
this. x minus 3's would cancel
out and you'd get this again.
So this is what we get when we
add the 2, and so this will be
equal to-- let me scroll down
a little bit-- this will be
equal to x plus 2x is 3x.
2 minus 6 is negative 4.
All of that over this thing.
We can either keep it multiplied
out, or factor it
out, or we could multiply it
if you like, but it'll take
some time to multiply it.
So I'll just say x plus
3, times x minus 3,
times x plus 2.
And we are done.